allerdings möchte ich euch jetzt das
krasseste zeigen was ich hier in
minecraft gespannt habe und zwar gebe
ich einfach diesen command eindrücke
jetzt enter und jetzt kommt echt was
sehr sehr krank ist und ich glaube wenn
mir das einfach so weiter entgegen läuft
dann würde ich mir schon die hosen
machen
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft heute am dienstag
und zwar hab ich ja an die alle die sich
wunderten wenigsten geriet in die auf
einmal wieder mit installiert werden
die kommen jetzt dienstags und freitags
weil ich immens viel effekt in meinem
posteingang herumflattern habt die alle
noch bei mir auf dem desktop gespeichert
sind und ich jetzt endlich alle mal
abarbeiten möchte so dass jetzt immer 56
pro folge komme die folgen kommen immer
dienstags und freitags und dienstags
kommt immer das geräusch das heißt
irgendwann in dieser folge wird
plötzlich ein geheimes geräusch
auftauchen was ihm in die kommentare
spam könnten alle die meinen aber dieses
geheimnisvolle geräusche regt mich nur
auf die können einfach jetzt wieder drei
tage abwarten bis freitag und sich dann
da die folge anschauen weil da kommt
dann kein geräusch und ich würde
allerdings dann wir fangen direkt an mit
dem ersten effekt und zwar wurde mir der
erste effekt zugesendet von der ta cco
und zwar schreibt der ta cco mit f4
entfernte die secret settings wieder ich
hatte ja oft gefragt wie ich dieses
super secret settings wieder entfernen
also ich bin zum beispiel erzielen den
option sind super secret settings und
kann jetzt ein paarmal auswählen
deswegen das hamborner das ganz gut
kennt jetzt hat man hier nämlich diesen
komischen wenn ich jetzt und ich hatte
dann immer das damals so gemacht und
fiel damit es auch geschrieben so lange
auf die super secret settings drücken
dass das ganze wieder normal ist es
dauert jetzt hier ein bisschen so
jedenfalls so lange drücken dass es
wieder normal man kann aber auch einfach
einmal f4 drücken und dann ist es ganz
wieder weg das ist angelehnt an dieses
alte 4 mit alter 4 macht man ja ein
programm komplett zu übrigens sehr
witzig wie viele darm infekt schreiben
mit mit alte 4 beim ist minecraft danke
danke oder wie viel bekommt man
diamanten da gehen wir aus ok egal
jedenfalls muss man einfach nur 434
drücken und dann bekommt man quasi
wieder die ganz normale ansicht hin und
ist auf jeden fall ganz coole sache die
ich jetzt immer anwenden werde wenn ich
irgendwelche secret settings habe und
dann kann dich der takko und wie kommt
erhält somit seine freunde ihr habt ja
gerade schon in zeitraffer gesehen dass
ich mir gerade im blick noch ein blog
dass sich das ganze grab gebaut habe das
war mehr als 1 travel bis in flint habe
ich herausbekommen und dort und jetzt
ist meine wurden schaufel nahezu
komplett im eimer und meine zweite
wurden schaufel habe ich gerade
angebrochen und dann habe ich mir noch
einen sound schaufel geklaut und geklagt
geholt und ich wollte euch ganz kurz
zeigen was man denn dazu gesendet wurde
und zwar von danny 1904 1904 des
auseinander geschrieben wenn du zwei
benutzte werkzeuge in einem 2 x 2 fällt
zusammen tust wird daraus ja einst
dieses hat ja sogar mehr haltbarkeit als
die zwei einzelnen wenn man verzauberte
sachen nimmt gehen diese weg also die
sache ist ganz einfach ideal bzw kommen
und ich dachte mir das geht nur mit dem
amboss das geht allerdings auch im ganz
normalen crafting menü und zwar wenn ich
jetzt dann wurden schaufel eines tons
offenlege geht es natürlich nicht
verlassen zwei unterschiedliche sachen
ich könnt ihr beispielsweise auch nicht
ein holzschwert mit einer eisen pigs
verzaubern und die sonne
sonne stein eisen im beschwert pixo der
irgendwie so einen schwachsinn das geht
nur mit den gleichen materialien das
heißt wunsch auf den wunsch auf ihr seht
schon dann bekomme ich eine neue und die
hat sogar mehr haltbarkeit also das wird
dann quasi darauf gerechnet und dann
bekomme ich diese neue schaufel und es
ist einfach so dass ich da nicht zwei
blöde schaufeln bei mir in der tat
sondern eine die einen wieder ganz in
ordnung ist und wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel diese stein schaufel noch
verzaubert haben möchte nicht sondern
auch mit einer anderen fasst kaputten
stein schaufel dann mach ich das auch
mit den steinhaufen es geht noch mit
schwertern und max und tatsächlich alles
also dass auf jeden fall ganz coole
sache und ich kann mit sicherheit schon
viele die sich über neuerungen immer
informieren aber es ging halt damals nur
mit dem amboss und deswegen denke ich
ist eine ganz coole sache danke an dich
denn iso freunde wir kennen sie eine 1.8
wurde ein spot hinzugefügt also ein
schwamm und wir können in schwaz einfach
irgendwo hinsetzen und dann zieht es
ganz wasser hier raus okay es kommt
jetzt wieder in welt ist ein relativ
großer see ist allerdings haben wir
jetzt hier so ein brett sponge den kann
ich jetzt einfach nämlich das mausrad da
draufdrücken kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich
kann ich mir den blog einfach holen und
jetzt habe ich einen spot schon ein red
sponge also einen nassen schwamm ich
habe hier aber hätte es gewundert schon
eine offen stehen und der timo hat mir
geschrieben wenn man einen nassen
schwamm in den ofen packt er wieder zu
einem normalen standards man muss ich
nicht nochmal so umständlich neuen
stammkraft obwohl so umständlich ist es
gar nicht sondern man kann ihn ganz
einfach mit kohleofen tun und dann wird
das ganze gleich wieder zu einem
normalen schwamm werden
und da haben wir auch schon den normalen
schwammen wieder und es können wir quasi
ganze hat man jetzt halt wieder normal
schwarm den also eigentlich wenn man den
abort im game zu null
dann geht er halt auch weg der schweiz
kein bug oder so einen krimi nach und
nach immer das ganze wieder besser
machen also besser aus richtung in
welche ozeane zerstören allerdings die
ganz große sache dieser effekt frau sie
beinhaltet ist einen nassen schwamm kann
man wieder trocken machen indem man
ihnen ein offenlegt und da ein
brennmaterial packt danke an dich timo
und der nächste aufgabe wartet der
nächste weg wurde mir nämlich ebenfalls
vom team und zugesendet und zwar der mir
commands gesendet mit denen man ein
zombie fährt ein skelett fährt und noch
etwas anderes als wenn wir nicht
gesendet hat aber was ich selber raus
gefunden habe und zwar hat er mir diese
sachen zukommen lassen und das ist
richtig richtig leid weil damit kann man
richtig spaß sie gekämpft eventuell
sogar veranstalten also man kann ja mit
dem begriff zu sammeln könnt ihr da wird
hier angezeigt sah man dann entity nahm
dann die koordinaten an den data tag
also was das von ptc und dann kann man
ja beispielsweise sowas von wie irgend
einen riesigen drachen oder irgendwie
sowas
und das macht mir das jetzt einfach mal
und zwar möchte ich erst mal dass
zombies panel zombies fährt das zombie
schwert zombie fährt spawnen aber dafür
mache ich erstmal das ganze teil hätten
damit also die sterben nicht bei tag
aber das was fans drittes bonn will
sterblichkeit bei tag und zwar ist das
hier erst mal das zombie fährt das sieht
erstmals ein ganz normales fährt ist es
allerdings grün und hört sich komplett
anders an
also so ein bisschen die sonne roboter
quasi das ist dieses zombie fährt das
sieht sehr sehr aggressiv aus wenn wir
das auch mal so sehen
heute habe ich hier außerdem mit bekommt
ein nationales pony von einem fat finger
drauf drückt dann kommen wir zur
nächsten sache und zwar dem skelett
fährt dann nehmen wir einfach genau das
gleiche schreiben type vor
und dann haben wir hier ein skelett
fährt sieht auch schon sehr sehr
gefährlich aus allerdings kommen wir
jetzt zur gefährlichsten sache und zwar
ihr habt ja gerade schon gesehen wie man
ein zombie fährt sport angesehen man ein
skelett fährt front und jetzt gehen wir
mal dass hier ein und drücken einfach
mal enter und wir sehen dass der in
wengen zum alles fährt raus kommen ich
mache normal im moment hat und ich
bearbeite noch mal ganz kurz diesen
gegeben habe
ich hatte bei den options das ganze auf
baseball deswegen konnte es nicht
gespart werden also wenn man das ganze
jetzt mal auf easy deswegen kann man nur
normales fertig wo lidl diese beiden
pferde sind ja nur die sehnen und böse
aus sie sind ja nicht wirklich böse
allerdings möchte ich euch jetzt das
krasseste zeigen was ich je in minecraft
gespannt habe und zwar gebe ich einfach
diesen command eindrücke jetzt enter und
jetzt kommt echt was sehr sehr krank ist
und ich glaube wenn mir das einfach so
im survival entgegen läuft dann würde
ich mir schon die hosen machen also
enter und wir haben ein pferd mit einem
skelett drauf sitzen
wir können einfach mal in den game auf
null gehen dass es gerade ein bisschen
blöd weil gerade überall einfach
irgendwelche teile sind und wenn wir das
ganze jetzt angreifen seht ihr schon das
fell des skelettes zwar keinen wir
werden jetzt aber schon von hinten
attackiert sich gerade also das ganze
schadet uns nicht es wird allerdings
klar skelettes pont das ganze dann
natürlich nur dementsprechend wenn wir
auch das ganze auf easy haben und ja das
ist jetzt quasi das krasseste was ich
hier gesehen habe das ganze gibt es auch
noch schön sterben das ganze gibt es
auch noch mit ein paar anderen sachen
und zwar beispielsweise des damals noch
spawn wenn man diese teils noch ein
bisschen bearbeitet dass das pferd auch
noch eine diamant rüstung an hat und das
skelett auch und alles mögliche kann man
ganz coole sache machen
die commands habe ich euch ja gezeigt in
dem video und das ist auf jeden fall der
vier defekte zugesandt wurde von timo
und auch das was noch hinzugefügt hat
mit dem pferd der das mit dem pferd von
einem sketch geritten werden das auf
jeden fall krankenhaus krankenhaus und
ich würde sagen die kommende werk so
freunde wir sind beim geheimnisvollen
geräusch angekommen ich will es gar
nicht so lange machen diesmal das letzte
gar nicht volle geräuschvolle raten von
razer du hast die canon legria mini
angemacht hat echten hat zu keiner
rausgefunden also das ist diese kamera
die ich auch immer in meinen videos und
blogs benutze die diesen coolen fischer
effekt hat ich hab ihr euch mal oben in
der beschreibung verlinkt falls ihr da
interessiert so etwas überhaupt keine
ist weil ich immer wieder fragen lese ja
was ist das für eine filmkamera ich hab
euch einfach mal um verlinkt kostet
relativ viel besser auf jeden fall den
preiswert und
was ich sagen wollte an alle die es am
anfang eventuell nicht mitbekommen haben
geräusch kommt jetzt immer nur dienstags
freitags kommt kein geräusch einfach
damit ich nicht auf geräusche machen
muss auch noch einfach damit die leute
die das geräusch nicht so mögen kann am
freitag schauen und die das geräusch
total feiern können am dienstag schon
und ich würde sagen wir machen das
heutige geräusch ist nämlich dass hier
wenn es erraten hab dann schreibt und in
die kommentare und eventuell mit ein
wenig glück seid in der nächsten folge
mit dabei und da würde ich sagen jetzt
gehts weiter in thun freunde kommen wir
zum fünften fekter mir zu gesendet wurde
von samuel und zwar kräftig mit
also mycroft 1 punkt wenn du auf den
rand von einem steinblock feld nimmt man
trotzdem fall schaden als weg entlang
blöcke wurden eigentlich hinzugefügt
eigentlich so als trampolin dass man
beispielsweise wenn man das in dem
stockwerk runterfallen will dass man
einfach auf dieses line blöcke darauf
fallen kann und dann tut es nicht weh
und man hüpft halt auch so ein bisschen
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise meinen
game mode 1 gehe weniger schaurig
vollidiot und hoch fliege und jetzt
einfach mal in den game zu null geht
seht ihr schon wenn ich runter fallen
mag ich bekomme keinen fall schaden ich
hüpfe hier oben
ich drücke nichts ich drücke hüpfende
einfach so ein bisschen rum nutze das
ganze quasi als trampolin
wenn ich allerdings wieder in den game
mode 1 kurz gehe und mich mal einfach
gerade ganz kurz auf den rand stelle von
diesen dingen einfach mal hier hin so
kann man ja mit nicken einfach
hinzunehmen wenn jetzt fliege ich
einfach mal hoch ich will mich immer
schon wieder in den game und 1 setzte
ich bin der kassieren und jetzt
gesetzlich nicht in den gamern 0
und lass mich quasi einfach fallen und
aufgedeckt kannte genau das geht hier
das geht auch ihr da geht doch hier das
geht auch hier auf der kante bekommt man
quasi jeden fall schaden den man so eco
bekommen würde allerdings ein bisschen
in abgespeckter form also eigentlich
würde ich beispielsweise wenn ich mich
jetzt mal hierhin stelle hier so auf den
hand gehe ich mal ganz kurz in denen gm
und fliegt relativ hoch ich würde locker
eigentlich alle meine herzen verlieren
würde ich sogar sagen oder zumindest
irgendwie ein annähernd fast sterben und
wenn ich jetzt so unterfalle kriege ich
halt nur die hälfte an schaden und das
ganze wird ein bisschen gedämpft durch
dieses live blogs aber sein blick aber
wenn ich quasi direkt in die mitte falle
bekomme ich gar keinen fall schaden
allerdings auf dem rand ist das ganze
schon ein bisschen krasser und das
perfekt nummer 5 und das waren auch
schon die heutigen minecraft ich hoffe
euch hat es gefallen
ich hoffe das geheimnisvolle geräusche
mitbekommen doch nicht nur einfach bis
zum ende gespielt sondern das ganze
video angeschaut wenn ihr jetzt immer
noch dran seid jetzt am ende des videos
dann schreibt man alle in die kommentare
hashtag villiger das mache ich immer
wenn ihr noch am ende dran seid dann
schreibt es auf jeden fall magath in die
kommentare
schreibt mir das geräusch in die
kommentare wenn ihr das erraten haben
und ich werde das wieder über die mail
machen über konkrete gmail.com ich weiß
eigentlich die kommentare machen
allerdings ist echt so unübersichtlich
und viele leute gehen darunter
und wenn mein posteingang ist es einfach
ein bisschen übersichtlicher kontraste
gmail.com und da könnt ihr die mails
entsteht doch noch mal in der
beschreibung und dann würde ich sagen
ich hoffe ich hab's gefallen wenn es
euch gefallen dann würde ich mich
definitiv meinen daumen hoch freuen
schaffen wir 5000 sehr heftig nice ihren
fälle jamba dies aber nicht vergessen
diese begrüßung zu machen mit welcher
bei die sich vollidiot potter reihe
lieben buddy es macht gut und